she's Kylie billionaire Jenner a
billionaire well not according to Forbes
which is unexpected because Forbes was
the first one to label her a billionaire
back in 2019 and double down on the
claim she's a self-made billionaire in
2020 starting a company on my own and it
being so big from the beginning there's
not a lot of room for mistakes in a
highly critical article published Friday
the outlet now alleges that Kylie has
lied about her earnings for years and
claims that she backed up the numbers
with falsified tax returns that like
makes me a little uncomfortable but
Kylie Jenner is shutting down the
allegations that she lied about her
finances she hit up Twitter to straight
up tonight it put the work in and it
really should work in in a series of
tweets Friday Kylie wrote I thought this
was a reputable site all I see are a
number of inaccurate statements and
unproven assumptions lol I've never
asked for any title or tried to lie my
way there ever period yeah she's not
having any of it guys and it didn't stop
there I would love my true fans to know
Kylie went on to write that she's
blessed beyond her years and is doing
perfectly fine adding I can name a list
of 100 things more important right now
than fixating on how much money I have
and saying this is the last thing she's
worried about also it's worth noting
that Forbes is now estimating her net
worth to be nine hundred million dollars
let's be real that's not that far off
from a billion not like that was handed
to her she figured that all out I mean
we all have et has reached out to
Kylie's rep for comment I'm the face to
my brand and I take responsibility for
everything that happens
[Music]